s'exprimer au travers de l'art une
révolte une souffrance une lutte et va
dt slameuse et poète originaire du
mantois propose un travail engagé
autodidacte en arts plastiques qu'elle
accompagne de ses textes bien nombreux
textes qui sont relativement fort et
assez assez brut donc qui relate de son
histoire et de son passé qui est un
petit peu difficile et donc la
traduction pictural sur son travail est
essentiellement liée à la condition de
la femme condition de la femme relations
hommes-femmes ou vision du corps féminin
autant de thèmes traités sur papier aux
matériaux de récupération par l'artiste
elle travaille ses créations sans
pinceau avec ses mains ou des bâtons en
mêlant acrylique huile et pastel
ce qui nous a plu c'est vraiment ce
travail très brut très spontanée avec
cette émotion qui est très forte que ce
que l'émotion soit positive ou négative
on ne rentre pas nous on ne sort pas de
cette exposition sans avoir rien
ressenti et c'est ça aussi qui nous
intéresse c'est à dire donner un moment
se dire des arts plastiques ce n'est pas
gratuit il faut que ça exprime quelque
chose ces créations sombre au coloré
brut spontanée à la frontière de
l'abstrait pour certaines sont à
découvrir au conservatoire des arts
plastiques de montigny le bretonneux
jusqu'au 25 mars prochain